when you uh when you when you wrote the
who i smoke record obviously first of
all whose idea was
that he's being crazy but he's a great
artist but he really
hard hard yeah for sure one thing about
him bro his work ethics craze through
the roof for sofi
no i mean obviously the genius idea
i for sure thought i was only going to
live on youtube i was like there's no
way that this girl's clearing this
record this is okay
it's gonna be a youtube classic vanessa
she dope so
it's so crazy because i wasn't even
feeling like fun to get on the song for
real well i was going to get on it you
feeling but
like i said it was like it was different
like you know what i'm saying and one
thing about spin he
he ain't afraid to do something
different you know what i'm saying walk
to walk crazy with it too
and go you know what i'm saying so they
put it on we all in the studio we just
vibing
so he been standing for a couple days
like oh we can do this drill time for
the
like you know what i'm saying so when
they put together he went in
then went in then when i went in i ain't
even mean to come like that like we
don't we don't sit there and write so we
just come on top of our head so
it's so crazy because i came it just
who yeah but everybody knew it was going
to be big like everybody knows
everybody had already heard the song it
was like a little like a little viral
little title going on
in the studio like that so yeah i
already knew this
and you and you thought to yourself i'ma
say these names on this song
and this is a good idea
it worked i mean obviously it's a hit
right for sure it's your biggest i mean
it's the biggest record you've been a
part of so far in your career
so yeah